In a womb,
in a world world or old world.
You know what?
Hey,
make sure your phone's turned off.
I think we're getting some feedback out
here.
A trailer boils down to four main
elements,
plot,
characters,
conflict,
and the cliffhanger.
Really,
each trailer is its own unique short
story that happens to pull all its clips
from one movie.
The only real difference between a
trailer and a short story is the
cliffhanger.
A trailer's main goal is to get people
to want to see the movie.
The cliffhanger is basically what's
missing from the trailer,
the part that has to be enjoyed by
purchasing an $11 ticket to see the
movie yourself.
So how do you make a trailer that's so
good?
It's safe to say the movie will do well
to stop.
Okay.
Safety first.
Safety is safety is first.
Let's look at the history of trailers
structure and see why.
Even today,
some trailers are still pretty
forgettable since the 1950s trailers had
a narrator basically just tell us the
four elements.
They'd say who the characters were,
what the conflict was,
the plot,
and whatever makes the movie worth
seeing.
Now here at Connie Tam and all the other
wonderful people and this unforgettable
stories,
clips from the movie only accompany the
narration.
So for the majority of cinematic
history,
the trailer was more or less a sales
pitch by some narrator.
Tell us the character,
tell us the conflict,
tell us why it's worth seeing and show a
few clips to keep us from getting bored.
Maybe throw in some silly music if it's
a comedy or something epic,
if it's action or drama.
Although some trailers from this time
were very well made.
The psychos trailer,
it's narrated by Alfred Hitchcock as he
walks through the bates motel and in
this house,
the most die,
a horrible event took place.
But as trailers had to get shorter to
fit into TV commercial breaks,
they became more formulaic.
Think about the stereotypical inner
worlds trailer.
It's a narrator telling us the
characters telling us the plot,
the conflict,
and the cliffhanger at new door cop,
John McLean to see his wife
and it's not just for action movies.
Comedies have a similar formula.
Tell us everything.
Sprinkle in some jokes along the way.
Her name is Samantha Baker and today is
her 16th birthday.
The problem arose when this format
became predictable and boring.
The inner world style of trailer now
gets parodied more often than actually
used in a world where laughter was king.
Uh,
no.
In a world.
Yeah.
I do have to be careful generalizing
though because while the majority of
trailers did follow the formula,
there have always been trailers that
stands out.
Yeah,
I need to talk to Mary came over last
night.
I want a salad last night because I was
upset that Joe was getting married and
before I knew what we were kissing and
nationally short we did it,
they take it,
but eventually even the average trailer
started getting more creative and most
importantly more efficient.
The short story of the trailer is
limited to around two minutes.
If there's any way to say more in less
time than perfect.
First cut out the narrator and
incorporate voiceovers from characters
in the movie.
This change makes the most sense.
If we use character voice,
so for,
we could have plot and conflict
introduced while also introducing the
characters.
So I'm going to have to science the shit
out of it.
Second,
we don't need the character telling us
the cliffhanger show,
the cliffhanger.
We want to see light sabers if we're
seeing a star wars movie,
so the best way to make a trailer for
star wars tease us and to the trailer
right before the light sabers hit,
the trailer is sending a message.
If you pay for a ticket,
you will get to see this.
Third is the built start with something
familiar,
something normal then disrupted.
Does it live on the Great Plains of
Africa?
No.
Hey,
make the clips,
get faster,
the music louder and then peak followed
by some resolution.
Many early trailers never did this,
but it's since become the norm,
but that's the problem.
These techniques have become so normal
that they aren't enough to make a
trailer stand out anymore.
The vague dialogue,
the over the top music,
it's very familiar to us.
Like that last line of the trailer
that's supposed to be really epic,
but it's so vague that it hardly makes
any.
Since I saw you,
I believed it was side.
It's something new can come into this
world.
One way trailers combat with monotony,
it's through making more unique trailers
where the sequence of shots gives the
four main elements instead of a
voiceover telling us the conflict and
telling us the plot with the right clips
from the movie in the right order.
We see the plot and conflict in the
American sniper trailer.
Chris Kyle has his sights on a child he
may have to shoot to protect his team.
Chris Kyle's internal conflict,
not addressed in voiceover but in the
sequence of clicks
and the cliffhanger,
whether he pulls the trigger,
maybe show a scene between the two main
characters in their secret identities
and cut back and forth between their
talk and them as superheroes.
I have a bad history with stress,
like clowns
show an entire scene in a movie,
not with cut after cut and not with
ridiculous music and voiceover in the
background.
Just a good scene that makes for a
memorable trailer and partly why the
furious seven trailer one the golden
trailer award.
I think in a lot of ways movie trailers
are like car commercials.
The majority of commercials are
relatively the same.
Show the car driving around and looking
cool.
While a narrator brags about the car,
half the car stop announced its name and
show the brand logo.
Obviously this type of commercial gets
car salt because it's used all the time,
but it's boring.
It may be cheaper and easy to write,
but it's so familiar.
It's the unique car commercials that go
viral or are really funny or different
that are probably the most valuable
because they create buzz and get shared
all across social media.
Pauline,
maybe most trailers will continue with a
more formulaic presentation of the four
elements,
but those ones that stand out,
the cool trailers,
do you want to share on facebook and
talk about with their friends?
Those are the ones with the bank for
their,
yeah.
Damn.